on lance tout de suite le hashtag spino
speedo si vous avez une phrase
philosophique on l'apprend apparaître
pendant cette émission
voilà et vous allez faire voilà préparer
une phrase voilà chacun la phrase qui
résume votre vie philosophiquement
chacun des chroniqueurs
la phrase la phrase philosophique qui
pourrait résumer votre vie caroline
alors elle est longue
ah oui si moi j'avais dit
[Musique]
et l'on y est très angoissé qui
réfléchit à côté qui c'est qui va venir
ici ça c'est que ça lui juste après et
là le mec je vois le vide dans ses vieux
bertrand est né comme ça [ __ ] c'est un
des côtés de transparents là mais savez
vous inquiétez pas ce sera à vous un oui
alors moi la phrase qui résume à vis et
impose ton bonheur certes à chance va
vers ton risque à te regarder ils
s'habitueront tatouages
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rien compris mais c'est par ces
paroles et c'est sam char rue des
charmes sur rhône est chargé monsieur
rené char c'est vrai que c'est rené char
la peur n'évite pas le danger
non c'est vrai ouais ah oui mais
attention pour eux vous dans la bien
nommée la peur n'évite pas le danger
[Musique]
quelle est la phrase qui résume votre
vie vous un tiens vaut mieux que deux tu
l'auras
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
euh non je toutes les femmes sont belles
près bien ton si c'est un mélange de
franck mickaël et francky basso ces
fraudes merci en tout cas en tout cas en
philosophie vous aider à avoir eu cinq
ça méritait pas mieux
[Musique]
il rappelle que vous êtes le patron de
télé 7 jours quelle est la phrase qui
peut le drame de notre époque c'est que
la bêtise pense c'est une phrase de jean
cocteau que je trouve assez juste pour
aujourd'hui sont cocteau jean jean yves
couteau lui coupant real alors et
blagues
telle est la phrase peut résumer voilà
votre vie la phrase philosophique
seul l'amour d'une femme nous donne la
force d'être heureux non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors elle est très très courte un jour
ça sera pire
vous avez le don de mac l'ambiance est
bien qu'elle me plaît mais un jour un
jour ce sera pire va merci bah oui on
sait avec vous c'est un sas et telle est
la phrase voilà qui tique
voilà qui vous représente vous quand on
ne sait pas où on va
vaut mieux y aller plus vite possible ah
ouais moi j'ai aussi quand on ne sait
pas où on va il vaut mieux acheter le
tomtom
[Applaudissements]
alors il n'aura quelle est la phrase
vous qui kim en avant guingamp
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la sto jean michel mr ses droits
tout doute pas toujours alors à nous une
vraie phrase wii play de coeur n'est pas
mortelle sinon je serais morte depuis
longtemps oui plein de coeur n'est pas
mortelle
jara compris j'aime beaucoup merci et
nora voilà comme ça on s'est un petit
peu
voilà on a on a mieux cerner vos
personnages qu'on vous connaissez pas
bien